Space.
Travel is the most exciting and challenging adventure humanity has ever
undertaken,
but in an irony of history,
we may stop ourselves from going into space.
The more we do it.
With every rocket launched and with every satellite deploys,
we are creating a trap for ourselves that gets deadlier and more dangerous every
year.
If it's ever activated,
it could end the space age and trappers on our planet for decades or even
centuries.
Yeah,
okay.
Guessing something into space is incredibly hard to do,
so you need to move very,
very fast at first,
straight up to leave the atmosphere,
then sideways to begin a sort of circling around the earth still very,
very fast.
If you do that successfully,
you can enter a low earth orbit and once in always,
it's very hard to get out of always unless you have energy despair,
you're sort of locked in here,
falling around the earth forever.
That's great for things.
We want to stay up like space stations and satellites,
and so we moved the majority of humanities space infrastructure to this place
just a few hundred kilometers above the surface,
just high enough so that the atmosphere is so thin that orbiting things can stay
up for centuries before our resistance can slow them enough to bring the back to
Earth.
But this is also the source of our deadly trap.
Rockets are really metal cylinders.
The key big piles of fueled in place.
Whenever a portion of the fuel has been spent,
the empty tanks are drops to make the rocket lighter.
Some parts crashed down to earth or burn up in the atmosphere,
but most of the useless rocket parts stay up and begin to orbit the planet.
After decades of space travel.
Low Earth orbit is a junk yard of spent boosters,
broken satellites and millions of pieces of shrapnel from missile tests and
explosions.
Right now we know of around 2,600 defunct satellites,
10,000 objects bigger than a monitor,
20,000 as large as an apple,
500,000 pieces the size of a marble and at least 100 million parts so small they
can't be tracked.
This debris is moving at speeds of up to 30,000 kilometers per hour.
So Lynn Earth on criss crossing orbits multiple times a day.
Orbital speeds are so fast.
The being hit by be the size of a pea is like being shot by a plasma gun on
impacts the debrief vaporizes releasing enough energy to punch holes straight
through solid metal.
So we've covered the space around our kindness with millions of deadly pieces of
destruction and we also put a trillion dollar global infrastructure network
right in the danger zone.
It performs critical duties,
essential to the modern world,
global communication,
gps navigation,
collecting weather data,
looking out for asteroids and all manner of scientific discoveries.
Things we would miss very much if they suddenly went away.
If just one piece size bullet hits one of our 1,100 working satellites,
it will be destroyed instantly.
Three or four satellites are already being destroyed this way every year as the
number of satellites and the amount of junk and orbit is expected to grow 10
fold in the next decade.
We're approaching a tipping point,
but the worst thing in space is not tiny pieces of junk.
The worst thing would be an unstoppable chain reaction that turns a lot of non
junk things into junk.
For example,
if two satellites had each other in just the right way,
if satellites collide,
they don't stop and fall out of the sky.
It's more of a splash that a crash.
Orbital speeds are so fast,
sorted pieces spray right through each other.
Transforming the two satellites into clouds of thousands of little things,
still fast enough to destroy more satellites.
This could trigger the slowest and most destructive sort of domino effects.
A collision cascade like a shotgun spray.
Each collision creates more bullets.
What was once a single tiny target,
very unlikely to hit anything becomes a war of destruction.
Hungry to make more.
As more and more satellites are destroyed,
the destruction accelerates exponentially.
Eventually destroying everything parked in obeys but speaks is very empty so the
first few collisions may take a long time.
By the time we realize what's happening,
it's too late.
One year one satellite is destroyed and that's no big deal.
The next year,
five the year after 50 until there's nothing left.
The situation in orbit is rapidly worsening and we may already be past the point
of no return within 10 years.
Space around Earth may no longer be viable for longterm satellites or rockets.
The worst case scenario is horrifying.
A debris field made of hundreds of millions of pieces,
many too small to track moving at a 30,000 kilometers per hour.
It would effectively create a deadly barrier around earth,
possibly too dangerous to cross dreams of moon bases.
Mars colonies or space travel at all,
maybe sat back centuries and the loss of our space infrastructure would send at
some of the technology we rely on daily back to the 1970s but it might not be
too late to clean up our mass.
While the space industry has become better at avoiding space junk,
it's still growing fast and occasional weapon tasks don't help.
So there have been a couple of wild but also serious suggestions about how to
quickly remove as much deadly space junk as possible without creating more in
the process.
Lots of ideas are being thrown around and some of the most seriously considered
involve capture and return missions which are being tested.
Now.
One method involves meeting a piece of junk in orbit with a small satellite and
loaded with a ask.
Once caused a small rocket could be used to bring it down towards earth targets
to lunch for an that might be instead caught with a harpoon on a tether.
Instead of firing a rocket,
the cleaner would deploy a large sale to produce atmospheric drag and accelerate
orbital decay.
And there are lots of other wild Saifai sounding proposals to some might use
giant electromagnets.
These magnetic tugs work by pushing on the magnetic components in site
satellites that they use to stabilize and orientate themselves in Earth's
magnetic field.
These may be safer and more reliable than nets and harpoons because they never
have to make contact with the junk they're handling,
so there's no risk of accidentally breaking up that target into more junk.
As for the tiniest bits of junk lasers might be the key to vaporizing them
entirely.
Satellites with lasers wouldn't need to visit their targets.
They can shoot them from far away.
Large objects can't exactly be shot down,
but lasers can be used to ablate or burn tiny amounts of material off the side
to push the junk to a safer or bet whatever technology we use at the end,
we better start doing something soon before 100 million bullets become a
trillion and the trap is set.
If we don't ask,
our adventure in space might end before it's even begun.
If our days of dreaming about space exploration might be numbered anyway,
we better put them to good use.
One of the things we most like to spend our time on is learning more about our
universe and to do that you can just keep watching codes cause aren't an
brilliant,
are collaborating on a six part video series.
About our favorite science and space topics,
codes,
because aren't,
has worked with brilliant for our best and we love how they teach you science
and maths in a practical way by guiding you through problems step by step so you
can actually understand the concepts behind them.
And maybe one day use your knowledge on problems like space junk or at least
your science projects to start with,
if you'd like even more edutainment,
goto brilliant.org/nutshell and sign up for free the first 688 people to use the
link,
get their annual premium membership at a 20% discount and also support our
collaboration with brilliant.